[Music]
a violent mob
attacked the u.s capitol on january 6
and disrupted the vote to certify the
2020 presidential election
after president trump urged them on at a
rally
npd dropped to uh capital command i'm
just advising you that uh
the entity has declared us a breach at
the capitol as well as a riot at the
capitol
a capitol police officer was killed and
four rioters died in the chaos
one shot by capitol police
[Applause]
the wall street journal analyzed hours
of video footage of the pro-trump mob
as well as emergency responder skinner
audio from the riot
and spoke to security experts including
a former head of the capitol police
terrence gainer to better understand how
a mob of thousands overran police and
attacked the nation's capital
threatening the safety of the highest
ranking officials in american government
[Music]
the journal found that the capitol
police failed both strategically
and operationally to secure the building
capitol police and dc metropolitan
police did not respond to multiple
requests for comment
in a previous statement the capitol
police said its officers were heroic
given the situation they faced
their union said the officers lacked
backup and equipment to control the
protesters
[Music]
it began at a rally challenging the
presidential election results
and we fight we fight like hell and if
you don't fight like hell
you're not going to have a country
anymore
by around 12 20 pm hundreds of raucous
protesters were making their way to the
capitol
while some headed for the east side the
majority approached directly from the
west
at 12 52 the protesters encountered
their first police presence on the
northwest side of the capitol
we can see only eight capitol police
officers none
are in riot gear they're standing behind
a temporary metal barrier
this type of movable barrier is meant to
signal that an area is off limits
not to stop a wave of violent protesters
the protesters quickly become aggressive
and easily push
through the barriers it's clear that
capitol police were not prepared for
this type of crowd
the small group of officers are quickly
overwhelmed and need to fall back
[Applause]
capitol police chief steven sund who has
since resigned said in a previous
statement that officers responded
valiantly when faced with thousands of
individuals involved in violent
riotous actions
the number of rioters is growing as they
rush the base of the capitol building
just a few minutes later by 12 57 we can
see capitol police scramble to form a
skirmish line further up the capitol
stairs
to prevent any further advance
a capitol police civil disturbance unit
or cdu
arrives to strengthen the line these
officers are more heavily equipped with
helmets
body armor and batons
they're also trying to spot the most
threatening actors and any ring leaders
visible in the sea of rioters are
individuals wearing military style gear
with kevlar vests
some have potential makeshift weaponry
like this bat and these flags
an orange colored tape and hats that
indicate that groups may be coordinating
their actions
at 110 about 10 minutes after the cdu
arrived the violence
escalates the mob begins to brawl with
the officers
here a flag is thrown hitting an officer
in the head
experts we spoke to say another riot
platoon should have been on the scene by
now
[Music]
instead we can see only a dc
metropolitan police bike unit has
arrived as reinforcement
these units are called because they can
get into crowded locations quickly
and their helmets bikes and other gear
offer some protection
rushing to re-establish the dividing
line they deploy pepper spray
but some of the mob counter with bear
spray a sign that they expected a fight
multiple uh officers injured through
west side
at 1 35 we see more metropolitan police
on the scene attempting to aid the
capital officers on the fast weakening
line
no more backup arrives and the officers
endure over an
hour of assault from the mob barely
holding on
at 141 we hear police put out a call
that is used to signal that a unit
is being overwhelmed broken arrow their
unit on city by with a priority
[Music]
by 228 more people are breaking through
the skirmish line
forcing officers to chase them down and
further weakening the line
then after nearly an hour and a half of
hostilities
the last line of defense between the
rioters and the lawmakers inside
finally breaks apart entirely sending
the scene into chaos
an officer is pushed off a ledge where
just below him a group of officers are
pinned
and assaulted with a fire extinguisher
more officers fall back
usa and once the skirmish line on the
west side
of the capital fails the mob storms the
building
as the scene spirals further out of
control the mob beats a fallen officer
on the ground and drags him down the
steps
an emerging timeline shows requests and
approvals for more police help
happening too late than too slow at
every turn
verbal approval to deploy the dc
national guard was not given until 3 pm
about 30 minutes after rioters breached
the capitol